the Western release of like a dragon
Asian is a curious proposition it's a
remake of the 2014 spin-off of the Core
Series and like the original relies on
intimate knowledge of the mainline
series for its experimental elseworld's
narrative to land and yet ishin is a
completely original story that has the
potential to serve as a good entry point
for newcomers looking for something
Standalone those who have been onlookers
to the Yakuza fever that has swept the
gaming landscape over the last few years
will most likely recognize many of the
characters in Asian from fan art
trailers and gameplay videos however the
versions featured in ishin are not the
characters we know and love but variants
living in a different era that might
sound like a peculiar turn off but at
the same time much of what makes the
franchise charming and its character's
endearing is also still present
Leica Dragon Eastern is set during the
turbulent late Edo period in Japan's
history which saw the end of the
infamous Tokugawa shogunate's 200-year
Reign ishin's protagonist Sakamoto Ryoma
who is physically identical to the
series main character Kazuma Kiryu is
involved in local political turmoil that
results in the assassination of his
mentor and father figure hell-bent on
finding the shadowy killer ryoma's
search brings him to the Shinsengumi a
special police force of the declining
shogunate evidence suggests that the
Assassin lies among its members and
Ryoma goes undercover to infiltrate
their ranks as those with experience
with the mainline series will no doubt
attest to and be drawn toward this is a
typical premise for a Yakuza game as it
places our hero on a righteous path in
which he must walk through treacherous
territory for newcomers taking a
detective plot akin to judgment another
Yakuza series spin-off and setting it in
this incredibly interesting time period
is a potent mix that may prove to be
attractive
either way the narrative is compelling
and based on what I played it
effectively kept me wanting more the
Yakuza and Leica dragon games are all
remarkably well told detective stories
combined with the exploration of
familial Dynamics and development of
earnest friendships and in the 45
minutes of the campaign I played much of
that was represented I was putting
together the puzzle and would help solve
the who done it mystery with the small
crumbs of information I had learned in
that time and some players may even
decide to build out that display in real
life to help them track the mystery I
also couldn't help but chuckle at its
absurd elements another series staple
the Leica Dragon Series has a passionate
following largely for its blend of
intense drama with light-hearted comedy
and in ishin that concoction has all the
charm that fans of the series have come
to expect with both drama and comedy
definitely weaving together to bring its
story to life that combination also
works its way into brawling gameplay
which is largely in line with the
mainline games that preceded it albeit
with much more sword and Gunplay this
time around
in combat there are four stances that
Ryoma can assume swordsman and gunmen
are self-explanatory the former has the
player wielding a katana and the latter
a revolver while the dancer sees Ryoma
wielding both while brawler is only
fists the upside being that the player's
hands are now free to pick up objects to
utilize As Weapons the default stance
swordsman is the one I initially
attempted though when facing off against
the previous first boss I found myself
struggling the series definitely has its
own flavor of combat that takes some
getting used to and I found that my
opponent moved too fast to give me the
opening I needed the same went for
Gunman it's too inaccurate to be
effective in a fast Close Quarters brawl
wild dancer however is where I came into
my own sacrificing my ability to block
to be rewarded with a much quicker Dodge
like the name of the stance suggests
attacks in this form are wilder than
when you're just wielding a sword or a
gun on their own the precise attacks of
those previous forms are replaced with
big swings of the sword the godsend when
locking on isn't an option I was able to
quickly get in a few blows and when my
opponent launched a counter-attack I was
rapidly able to get out of the way
before swinging my sword to break his
stance I followed up a few slashes of my
Katana with a shot from My Revolver
which often knocked him off his feet and
left him open for a finishing move
what was proving to be a troubling fight
my first few attempts was now an even
matchup and I ultimately bested my
adversary in short order as I found my
footing I was able to experiment more
with the hardest answers once I
understood the benefits and drawbacks of
each form and got back into the flow of
like a dragon's rigid movement I played
around with the different options during
my second confrontation and came out on
top without having to rely on just wild
dancer I even gave brawler a shot which
is easily the most difficult of the
force dancers to be effective there were
a few encounters I had with
run-of-the-mill bad guys as I moved
through the environment and this is
where the game's comedy really came into
play one specific interaction had a trio
of Bandits charging at me with their
swords before I Unleashed shots from my
revolver with infinite ammo The
Swordsman couldn't get past my wall of
bullets and while my lack of combat
creativity didn't net me a particularly
high rank once the smoke cleared it was
worth it for the hilarity of the moment
while most should have a blast with the
combat and the story of the game one
might prove to be more divisive for
newcomers are side activities like
karaoke and dancing minigames though
seemingly throw away distractions in the
series side activities are usually quite
involved and Incredibly fun if you've
existed on the internet in the last few
years you'll no doubt be familiar with
the bakumatai phenomenon
[Music]
which is proof that you may find these
activities more meaningful than you
think additionally they are meant to
flesh out the world of the game as you
go through so I am Keen to see if the
full experiences characters and story
really sink their teeth into me like
this preview suggested they might
[Music]
like a dragon Asian has all the elements
of the other titles in the franchise but
is doing something fun with its world
and characters it's newcomers that might
have a tougher time jumping in but the
promise of its story and the variety of
its combat I saw in the preview make a
compelling opening argument for why
ishin should be a great gateway to the
series for them
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]